These villains that we now have in our
universe happen to be characters that
are in the sinister six there may be
something that happens with that. No matter
where he goes the world is going to be
different for him. Here's the real
blockbuster
brace yourselves you might want to sit
down. Spider-Man's name is Peter Parker
what though no more hiding yeah no more hiding.
One of I think our great hopes for
future films is other articulations of Venom.
As fans the comics will know
Carnage is the bond between Cletus Kasady
a serial killer and the red symbiote and
so this movie will introduce Cletus
Kasady hi Eddie carnage is the promise
of the venom character taken to the next
level so you know going into venom you
were hoping that there'd be carnage and
they delivered in a very delightful way
that made you go alright I'll give you
more of my money if you do this again!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man 3 sinister
6 video and a breakdown of the
spider-man 3 title as you can see in
that clip Amy Pascal reveals their plans
for a sinister six team up movie but
reportedly she also revealed that the
title of spider-man 3 will also have
home in the title like the other
spider-man movies so there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter egg videos we're doing a new
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for what the title of
spider-man 3 is going to be so we'll
start with the spider-man 3 titles then
I'll talk about the sinister six teaser
and how that's coming together based on
what the Sony and the Marvel people are
saying in the MCU and the characters
that would combine to make the MCU
version of the sinister six just going
down the list here starting with number
5 if you didn't see the news this past
week there was a report that Amy Pascal
confirmed home would be in the title of
spider-man 3 that's not a big surprise I
always felt like they intended to make a
trilogy of new spider-man solo movies
when they started in Captain America
Civil War Hollywood loves their
trilogies they're just stuck on that
number
why make one movie when you can make
three movies they kind of confirmed
their plans when they kept the home
thing in the title was spider-man far
from home and for spider-man 3 they even
continued the working title joke from
the previous two movies continuing the
theme if you didn't realize it each of
the spider-man MCU movies working titles
have been Seinfeld jokes
spider-man homecomings working title was
summer of George which is the title of
an actual Seinfeld episode the working
title of spider-man far from home
was fall of George that's not the title
of an actual Seinfeld episode it's just
a joke about them movie taking place a
little while after the events of
spider-man homecoming because of the
timing of the Avengers infinity war snap
in the Avengers endgame blip that they
reference at the beginning of the movie
and even though we had blipped away
halfway through the school year and had
already taken midterms the school made a
start the whole year over now this year
the working title of spider-man 3 is
serenity now which is another George
Costanza Seinfeld reference you all
remember the memes after spider-man at
bar from Holmes post-credit scene
everyone joking about spider-man 3 being
spider-man homeless because now all the
sinister six villains know his secret
identity they'd be able to find his and
Aunt May's house using a basic Google
search so for what are the most likely
titles for spider-man 3 that actually
sound legit in themselves informed the
action of the movie like the homecoming
in spider-man homecoming was all about
him coming home to Marvel after being at
Sony for a long time bit of a meta
reference but also him coming home from
his Avengers field trip with Iron Man
and Captain America Civil War and about
the homecoming dance at the end of the
movie that he almost kind of goes to you
before bailing to go fight the vulture
spider-man far from home was about him
literally being far from home in
Avengers infinity war dying far from
home then coming back from the blip and
then going far from home literally when
he was in Europe during his class field
trip fighting Mysterio so if spider-man
3 is about him having his secret
identity being revealed to the entire
world all of his villains coming for him
declaring open season on spider-man and
trying to prove that he's innocent and
Mysterio faked the video what title
conveys all those ideas in a really
simple way knowing what we do know about
the movie here my top picks right now
spider-man war at home which is also a
play on Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame and the idea that he's
going to be in for the fight of his life
then there's spider-man homefront which
is also a play on the battle close to
home because it's implied the movies
going to take place in and around New York
City that was what that ending scene was
all about with them finally showing him
web slinging through the New York City
Building us again there's spider-man in
a run home because now all of his
villains know who he is it also makes
Aunt May a target and as worried as it
might be for his own safety what was the
things spider-man was
most worried about during spider-man far
from home Mysterio hurting the people
that he cared about threatening their
lives but this time in spider-man 3 Aunt
May is in very real danger and then
probably the most likely title that
actually sounds like a real movie title
it would be spider-man home run just
because it's way catchy er and still as
a bit of a play on the team up battle of
it all the reference the spider-man will
soon be facing multiple villains at the
same time another sinister six teaser
but just to be clear I don't think that
spider-man 3 will actually be Marvel and
Sony's full-blown sinister six movie so
three talking more about the sinister
six teaser of it all we almost have a
full six members between all the MCU
spider-man movies in the upcoming Sony
venom verse spin-off movies and the new
characters are getting ready to
introduce everyone remembers the amazing
spider-man 2 sinister 6 post credit
scene and Sony's plans to turn the
sinister 6 into their own spin-off
franchise of movies separate from the
main spider-man movies if you don't
remember what Sony's plans were amazing
spider-man 3 when they were still going to
make that movie wasn't going to be
sinister six it was going to go amazing
spider-man 2 sinister six then they do
amazing spider-man 3 then they do
sinister 6 2 and so on and so forth
so the sinister six movies were kind of
like their own separate spin-off
franchise the way they had planned to do
that originally is that spider-man would
just be dropped into the events of that
movie then they would put him back in
Queens with Aunt May before amazing
spider-man 3 picked up in the events of
that movie would be completely different
the reason that Sony still wants to
structure things kind of like this is
because they get to release more movies
at the end of the day and make more
money
why make three spider-man movies when
you can make four or five spider-man
movies the benefit of doing it that way
is that you also have more time to
develop the sinister six villain
characters before you Jam them all
together in the same movie for a team-up
that's why even though there will
probably be multiple villain cameos in
spider-man 3 just to help continue
setting up sinister six all evidence
still points to spider-man 3 focusing
mostly on one main villain like the last
two spider-man movies first it was
vulture with a couple lackeys than it
was Mysterio with a few other lackeys
right now all the interviews from the
cast and crew and the director make it
sound like Kraven the hunter will be the
villain of Spider
and three but they haven't confirmed
that yet there is some evidence in the
Morbius movie that they're getting ready
to introduce Kraven the hunter which is
why it just seems like all signs point
to Kraven being the spider-man 3 villain
we already saw that vulture sinister six
cameo seen during the Morbius trailer so
it's all just them continuing on the
path of setting up this big sinister six
movie but now they're also using all
these venom Morbius spin-off movies to
do it - so - who is Marvel's sinister
six right now and who's missing so right
now they have vulture the second version
of the Shocker the Tinker the Scorpion
Kraven the hunter as teased during the
Morbius movie who seems like he's going
to debut during spider-man 3 and then
obviously Mysterio who the producers
have implied faked his death or may have
faked his death in far from home I know
everyone wants an MCU Doctor Octopus
because dr. octopus is the one in the
comics who put the first sinister 16
together but Marvel and Sony have
already changed so much about the
spider-man and venom verse characters
that I think is kind of foolish to
assume that they won't also change the
origin of the sinister six Tom Hardy has
been posting a bunch of venom stuff
recently so it sounds like they still do
plan on releasing venom 2 later this
year and maybe a trailer before the end
of the month but number one what about
venom 2 spider-man venom crossover and
venom being involved in future sinister
six movies and what about spider-man 4
if Sony already confirmed that they have
spider-man 4 plans right now without any
big changes spider-man 4 would be
released sometime in July of 2023 if
they're doing spider-man movies every
two years the way they talk about the
venom spider-man eventual crossover
sounds like that'll be something
separate from what their sinister six
plans are venom is being set up as an
antihero inside the venom verse so I
don't know if venom would be involved in
helping spider-man with any sinister six
problems but you guys can let me know in
the comments do you actually want to see
venom cross over into a sinister six
spider-man movie or do you want to keep
that venom spider-man crossover stuff
separate there was a big report recently
about what's going on with Marvel's
plans for setting up the next big
Avengers movie which would be Avengers 5
that'll probably be my next video I'll
try to post that as soon as I can
everyone click here for that brand new
John Krasinski Marvel phase 4 clip and
click here for all my Iron Man Avengers
infinity
Saga Marvel phase four Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe I'll see you guys tonight!